this video is sponsored by liquid IV
more on them after the reaction
people what is happening there citizens
of the reject Nation I joined with Aon
Alexander here to watch a classic comedy
that I don't know about only thing we
know is Andrew Gordon decided to do his
impression of the main character saying
his name that's all I needed to know you
did that yesterday remember he like a
major pain or I don't know what he said
I vaguely remember I tune him out it's
major pain we're watching today Aaron
how are you you know what I got this
this uh this I got my sciatica acting up
so it's real it's a real major pain in
my side do you really have a sciatica
thing or no my mom does though you just
wanted to make that major pain J it did
it was it was a stretch but you know we
made it we made it here we arrived yeah
good good
video hey top tier comedy baby like on
this video also subscribe click that
Bell to get notified when we got a
reaction up for something else on this
channel tell us in your the comments in
your comments what you think about the
major pain or if there's other comedy
classic comedies you think we should
check out prepper thank you for editing
this down full length re watch sing with
your own copy of MJ pain is available
for our super sex rejects over at our
patreon page over there we cover several
things exclusively with highlights and
watch SS included Aaron you ready to do
this I'm ready Sergeant yep yep yep
that's how he sounds that's Andrew's
impression rough watch let's do
this
[Music]
oh born to be damn okay double Universal
let's go p p to the phone porn of you
wild
stupid you
repetitive on the day I was born Born to
Be
[Laughter]
Wild wife and kids that's the name of
his show
okay I thought this came out beforehand
I guess it was during it might have name
his production
company oh
dang the
hell I'm
triggered
badass follow
me damn it's like they opening a
Terminator
[Music]
oh my God he's like a super
badass he's good at his job Miss shot
okay oh that's not
funny me show you little
trick take your mind out
that that you may feel a little fresh
e
e Jesus it
to what was the objective man to
distract him from his
arm it's horrible absolutely horrible
Aaron you can't argue with his
methods major pain
[Music]
indeed you had better give up seor you
cannot kill us all no
but I can clean your
quick no thank you burritos with extra
guac were like o the promotion board
report came out last week this is the
new lieutenant colonel list your name is
not on it two chances to advance then we
got to show you the hatch the hatch you
trying to tell me in all this man's
military there's no room left for a
trained weapon of
Destruction the gold to is killing
man you got to be somebody needs some
[Music]
killing anybody you've killed them all
you've killed them all every single
one you're too good at your job man like
how he's playing it with a sense of
sincerity whole week since I killed me a
man and already I'm get the itch problem
is I ain't got nothing to
scratch God I'm hungry you're going to
find something just you wait oh hell no
blood no no no no I'm just
playing oh
[Music]
no it's like Apocalypse Now I got to
keep my strength up got to maintain
discipline because yeah this is
Apocalypse
Now this is a dramatization of a
domestic violence dispute you arrive on
the scene to find a woman played by Miss
Goodman claiming to have been assaulted
by her husband played by Mr Shipman
happy to meet you s this is going to go
terrible your objective is to
effectively neutralize the situation
uhoh WR choice of words uhoh oh he knows
it's
killing he hit me uhoh you like to beat
women
you like to beat
women that is a
jail that's hilarious he's too good at
his job what happened you've only been
out one week it's cilian life sir I had
a Mana set
man I got an assignment for you it's not
great you understand but it gets you
back in the military he's so thirsty for
it he's so ready for violence it's not a
spoof of the military vets it's a spoof
of the movies that do this oh yeah smart
I was told it would be my greatest
challenge it was sure to be a living
hell all right let's see
it you like a boarding school or
something
the G Club will be
meeting 3 give be a teacher oh my God
keep this man far away from children
Tiger Tiger come back here I'm not going
to chase you what a cool name a no he's
going to build up some real morale in
these children he's going to teach them
about The Facts of Life what you running
from boy she's trying to get me a shot
you don't like needles want me to show
you a little trick take your mind off
that pain oh
no no please don't do it now you may be
a little bit of a PR no don't do it not
to the not to the little boy counselor
Hillary oh for fresh yeah that's a
fine handshake you got
you you
[Music]
want come on nice meeting you major nice
meeting you Miss ma'am but she's playing
a smart person what up of her
[Laughter]
range oh your place
girl pull together man maor pain
reporting for Duty
sir thought that was a fart sound same
yep you're in charge of the green boys
they wear those green things is that a
beetle walking across in front of bushes
I can't see them did they get real bugs
it looks like it I understand you've
been placing last eight years running
into Virginia Military games I am here
to remedy that I don't care what you do
with those boys as long as you keep them
out of my
hair falling movie you idiots let's
go oh he's going to have his work cut
out for him Aaron oh Lord he's going to
have his work cut out for him he's going
to have to whip these Misfits into
shape they're a bunch of
dweeps nerds even major Bon W pain as
of I am replacing maor Frankford as your
[Music]
[Laughter]
commanding whoa what are you doing man
now what we have here is a failure to
communicate to turn you maggots into a
well disciplined Cadet unit from this
day for what you're sorry asn't Belong
To
Me Drake blow your nose or even dig in
your butts without my say so it's a lot
of rules killing is my business ladies
and business is
good I have to go to the bathroom you
hold it
[Laughter]
I said hold it or I'll break that up and
kick it around on the
ground I've heard some of these quotes
but I never knew they were from this
movie I did something
B is that Orlando Bloom Orlando Brown I
mean go change your hugging boy and be
back here fronto stop that cry a you
think your tears will stop Charlie from
taking his b and sticking in your little
tiny heart he's going to have to learn
to be
softer what the hell was that you little
Freckle face cartoon this move is going
to have a lot more heart than expected
that's what I'm thinking did I give you
permission to sneeze open no sir hold it
in you big turd otherwise I kick your
ass back
to no wrong
person drop down give me 25 pushup
one
uhoh what are you laughing at pig
boy
ouch you know you remind me of the dough
boy if I poke your stomach will make you
[Laughter]
go up right now let
go let me see that roll
oh God let me see that belly
roll who you red
fox do y'all not learn bro WR this kid
what's your name
girlfriend call me dick you call me you
like the way I handle the white
boy feel good black man run
back yeah brother why you come close ah
I not your damn brother now me Squad
now this is great what are you looking
at ass ass nothing sir you plotting on
me boy no sir well let me tell you
something ass ass
eyes and when a man get eyb at me and
make my asent jack up and I get the to
kill you me so you Jesus
and what is your damage muscle head you
ignorant or you just plain old death yes
sir he is Dea oh oh oh damn I'm sorry Mr
handicap
man if you don't answer me when I speak
to you I'm going to put my foot in your
[Laughter]
ass
no oh
God
course the ADR that line hey
guys who's this guy he's the cool kid
looks like we got another major on our
hands here guys oh he's the one who
wields the real
power oh wow I think he really shaved
his head oh damn they all really shaved
their
heads you will walk like me talk like me
oh poor guys
all right d take these men two hour a PT
yes sir first exercise will be the side
[Laughter]
Str I love his fervor there were these
kind of like 90s movies of stranger
mentoring students and some capacity
yeah there's a theme there could you
please help me to understand why you
shave the children
bals oh that's my little incentive
program these boys had to earn it do
that
is do they have to earn their bathroom
privileges
too told on him he's upset about this
morning apparently he had a little
accident apparently he pissed all over
the front of his
pants well maybe that's because he's six
woman when I was six years old I had a
full-time
job
a full time job you think I owe you an
apology I'm sorry you're just a little
turd that can't hold your liquid out in
public oh you get on out in my face
while I pick you up and toss you out
that
window adorable I think that has a
little kid in fresh prins I think that's
little Orlando Brown ah damn I don't
know I'm likely to trust your instincts
for no specific
reason do you know what positive
reinforcement means you take a PO and
you snap his neck after you TOR him so
you don't have to go through life with a
colost
bag I'd like to make a suggestion why
don't you and I become Partners
emotional growth and development of
these little ones oh that's an
interesting turn what do you say I would
say yes I mean look at her I can't look
at her she's too
unattractive oh my go she's talking
sexual yes
yes good oh she knew what she was doing
of course of course she does you women
ruining
me you'll be the death of
me man that damn pain already starting
to get on my nails while he's eating
candy they're counterproductive there
buddy get off
ow what a jerk bag Pain's going to kill
us you know I have a heart condition I'm
not sure he's familiar with my medical
history I have good news for you
pack your beding your kid and
your clothes let's
go welcome to the House of Pain house
oh my God he got so many snacks sir I
think I speak for everyone when I say
that this place is unacceptable what are
you
doing
[Music]
really the absurdity of the drill
sergeants my little sprout uproot
yourselves I like that
shot tomorrow L we going to start the
hard stuff they really put these
children through the
ringer you get no sympathy from me you
want sympathy look at the dictionary
between
[Laughter]
simp you really makes this movie he's so
funny yeah don't fly baby
fly
I love that guy he's so good if we don't
get across that rope I'mma hang him with
it they'll hang you with
it he loves it over that take your fat
over shut
up come on he can't do it leave him
alone I can barely do it everyone really
looks up to him he's like the real
leader yeah he could be there's a lot of
potential in him they're feel they're
going to earn each other's Respect by
the end of the F end of the movie
what if this was a life or death
situation but it's not a life or death
situation it is
now uhoh he do it too I don't I don't
doubt him come on guys what are you
crazy it's just a dummy grenade no it's
not
oh he's costing the school a lot of
money concentrate to finally what the
hell was that it's like a super laxative
this here will pack enough punch to take
out entire football team oh that is
messed up P will never get off the can
he'll be made beef sto till graduation
these kids could easily be misconstrued
for something else in in the wrong
context so I don't know what you're
talking
[Music]
about I mean in a weird way he's
bringing in the unit together because
they all have a common enemy which is
him yeah it's very true there's a call
for you
sir oh he knows what's
[Music]
up look at them they're
strategizing
yeah uh-oh now do you think bring them
together by making Comm common enemy as
his his intention or just like the
adverse effect of what he's trying to I
think adverse yeah I think the ladder
there's a surprising amount of heart
there's actual story here yeah I thought
it would just be a bunch of silly gags
based off the front
cover no yeah it's it's we I like the
team we have so far and there a
narrative here exactly
yeah I feel like having these kids there
balances out from his ridiculousness
uhoh things about to get shitty damn he
swallowed that whole He golfed that
down it's not going to work that fast
come on no way for the sake of a comedy
erron and the name of comedy in the name
of Comedy super fast
acting
laxatives don't give him you're giving
him the look knowing that you the one
who did it oh you can take it
get he's trained for this my man his
body's probably immune Heats poisons for
fun that was well well edited that was
great cut to the Wi happens that was
really well
timed I keep wondering if this guy's GNA
be if he's like the villain of the movie
or if he's going to amount to like being
some kind of leader like a real leader
feel like he's going to be the leader um
I feel he's going to go through
something that humbles him and then
makes him the real leader I'm actually
curious about where the story is going
to
go hours he hasn't
[Laughter]
blinked love how exaggerated of a Lethal
Weapon he
[Laughter]
is he's killing machine this one's
prettier man you sure about this he
looks away to me I checked
[Laughter]
on see he's dead to the
world let's go visual gag works so well
because of the breathing up and down of
the stomach right get in can I just
stand beside the bed get in oh jeez this
is going to
backfire so stupid you shouldn't do his
kids don't do it he's going to he's
going to punish you guys so
bad this is such a terrible IDE
day how is he not woken up okay he's
faking he has to be
closer now put your arm around oh jeez
come on
guys
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I love how delicately they close the
tripod so
[Music]
funny ma major a
major a when
we that's squat when we piss I tell you
ladies you're the Prest unit ever
underneath my command I think he's
really whipping them into shape though
really making them a unit his unorthodox
methods I thought we had a little talk
about this kind of negative
reinforcement she going to be my big
helper yeah but they started
it
don't
No don't touch my whistle touch the
whistle they may not like me but they
will respect me let me be more direct
they hate you good draw them close
together make them a team aha attention
i' would like you to consider an
alternative
approach I want you to have this book
role model the ABCs of the loving male
role model I don't need your book take
it I don't want it take it I don't want
it please major take it doesn't matter
even if you know she's faking just do it
the power of Seduction I mean they need
to be punished for what they did I mean
they are technically yeah I I'm not
really on her side on this one they got
to maybe even worse I feel like in real
life someone did that they'd be punished
much worse than just having to wear
dresses he's getting more into the book
surpris is actually reading it I just
came by to let you know that williger
has a slight temperature so you might
not want to torture him this evening I
will be
sensitive to his needs pointing in the
machete have you been reading the book
well I might have glanced at it once or
twice well that's very good I'm very
proud of you m it's such a child oh come
on he's back he's back he's all around
the man myet boy get on out of here with
that I'm scared of crap go on now get
but this is not military
training hello there fella it's called a
nightmare why don't you run on back to
your room for that man jump at the CL
and CH your little head
off halfway
there progress
s let me give you a little history on
Kevin Dunn car accident
1989 lived in the chest that often is
till 1991 when the school adopted him I
know all about it he needs right now is
a sadistic Father Figure scaring the
life out of him it's not sadistic he's
toughing him up get him to ready for the
future out and let boy grow
up they're going to learn from each
other stop babying him I don't call it
babying I call it nurturing and I call
you an insecure overbearing Psychopathic
dictatorial eom mancal Frid lunatic
he's still there you want to see
nurturing
uh-oh uhoh he in
there oh
no oh
jeez heing there he ain't happy m yeah
it
happened P just terminate that Batman
with extreme prejudice and if he still
in there he ain't
happy way to solve the problem you got
to shoot your way out of things b b
ain't going to bother you no more thank
you
major
a I love
[Laughter]
you a great reaction let's go your angle
boy you plotting on
me snap your neck at 20 different places
major major it's
okay he's just trying to show you some
affection I don't like
it
[Laughter]
bul uhoh uhoh she's falling for the
softness in
him good night Miss there's a boy
underneath that rough
exterior I have to fix him says
something about her if she's falling for
him you know right this teaches women
the wrong lesson this is why they fall
into abusive toxic relationships
gaslighters she's anxious and he's
avoidant yeah she's trying to fix
him can't fix it's not Good's not here
he's in our ass
is our ass so tight he gas so tight he
can't pass
gas get it you got
moves who's this
ooh Steve Austin all right he's a
little thick for Steve Austin John
[Laughter]
Goodman
yo you pain I got something to say to
you that's not JN
[Laughter]
good what be
you did he hire this guy to whoop his
ass to get respect I hope so you know I
heard you've been giving these boys a
hard time in fact I heard you couldn't
cut it in a real man's military I think
he hired him I heard your mother she
played pool with the
[Music]
planets ooo you thinking about leaving
yet well actually I think the party just
begun it's exactly what he's been
looking for right he's been thirsty for
[Music]
it there you go there you go
said you going to hit me in the face
what you calling me a
[Music]
li somebody's going to answer for this
blood from my lip I want names all of
them I guess nobody's responsible guess
I just had that one of
coming well you know what y'all got
coming 7 20 three hour days full of fun
and
Adventure I'm going to make you boy
strong it was me sir I hired him well
that's one death warrant son I acted
alone sir the rest of the squad was
unaware of my activities he's taking the
fall within that's not true is it it's
not true I don't think
so he's the
leader
selflessness that's it sure sir you are
no longer the squad leader what stone
you are now Cadet sergeant if these men
win the Virginia Military games it'll be
because you had led them to a victory
ooh that's a nice turn yeah if they lose
it'll be because you failed them I like
how major P are have such a caricature
and then he's become like a real
character yeah yeah like the the
character aspect is just a facade facade
but like to disguise what the actual
character
is like H in high order raising the bar
I feel like they really had to train
these kids before doing this comedy oh
yeah there's like a lot of physicality
invol I want that trophy if your tur can
bring me that trophy I will resign my
command if you are discovered I will
deny all knowledge and you will pay the
price damn he's a really good leader
yeah he knows what he's doing we got two
miles to get to Willington let's get in
out of there as fast as we can let's
hustle move it go look at that he's
becoming he doesn't even realize it what
you think I'm going to come and help you
make me look bad anyway I've called my
dad leaving this stupid School you salty
little baby I'm going to the blackout
you can't come you're too little why
don't you stay back here and guard the
base okay young Orlando Brown kid from
fresh prella whoever you
are what's the matter with you boy they
won't let me going to Black Op they say
I'm too little what about all the
stories about the little people that do
big things Little Red Riding Hood Three
Little Pigs
Le or them little rasers you ever hear
the story about The Little Engine That
Could let me tell you that story this it
going to be accurate he's using some of
that softness some of that sensitivity
training he was chugging his way across
the enemy
line this little engine mission was to
take some
AK47s that was pled
opposition you think that stopped The
Little Engine That cut no he just kept
chugging along she comes at the right
time Dam wow look how soft he can be
popped out the eyes of conductor
blood did that stop the in the C damn
skip me he just kept chugging along
CH it wasn't until Charlie rigged the
bridge with plastic explosive uhoh just
as The Little Engine was making his way
across the
dresser blood and gut and spitting ass
was every
everywhere I can't feel my legs they
ain't
there I look down and them little bloody
n was kicking real
fast 30 miles did a Nast T unless you
can flip upside down and work on your
head you ain't going to make it how many
stories is he
combining just me and my side and I had
no other alternative but the blast my
way
out B I saw what you
did this went so South so
fast you just missed a little bedtime
story no I didn't actually I'd love to
talk to you about that story perhaps
over dinner oh snap drawn to the pain
this is not going to be healthy
relationship I want to do the sequel to
this that does a very realistic take on
it where they be at in 30 years from
now oh my God he changed this is not the
place to have a quiet
conversation God
damn
as you do I think Damon wayes really had
to scarf all that down and they just
sped it up how many takes you're right
that was almost a really good thing you
tried to do for Tiger tonight they make
a
suggestion
proceed well your story while colorful
bit rough you mean explosion yes and the
context the gouging part you need to
loosen up not everything can be about
war she likes him for his
[Music]
potential it's dangerous
territory I like to hang upside down
blindfold and then I take my gunot and I
put it back together real fast before my
nose start to
bleed but is there anything that you
like that doesn't have to do with battle
like
golf
negative dance I don't suppose you dance
I dance in
[Music]
Vietnam I've been known to cut a little
rug in my
day oh no
is a you
dance
stop judging him that's how he
dances he's expressing himself he can
pop and luck stun double it
[Laughter]
[Music]
to he's the constant center of
attention
okay there you go that's something you
can do
together oh no
R yeah get it pop it the hell was
up you take these guys and fan out the
Left Flank of the school go got you take
these two and cover the right got it got
she can heal him and make him softer him
major pain this guy's doing great oh
yeah he's killing him
man come on realize you want to win it
the right
way oh no you're going to get caught oh
is it the
[Music]
principal
janitor don't move
he's going to get
[Music]
expelled yeah we faster than that man
run
[Music]
dang don't abandon them oh yeah you're
done oh you're done in
rings oh no maybe that one kid that
stayed behind can help them I keep
trying to figure out how smart major
pain actually is where how much just
happens by
chance I got something for you oh what
is it it's a
bullet it's from my
heart literally he survived well where'd
you get it from my heart left ventricle
I took it out myself with a field knife
he's such a great military man and they
just threw him
[Music]
away terrible the beginning of a long 30
years terrible idea is this really the
man you'd want to raise your children
with what the hell are you doing in my
office it was a
trap you set us up I might have made a
little Anonymous call oh we got the crap
kicked out of us because of you tonight
wasn't about Fair unfair it was about
achieving your objective did you even
see that trophy hey I did did you want
it I wanted it to own it yeah deserve it
yeah to win it oh yeah he's got him if
you really want it I'll show you how to
earn
it he's going to shoot major pain right
now what the hell happened to
you Michael Ironside what are you doing
here it's parents day and I am your
legal guardian oh God drunk
don't you walk away from me give me a
little salute I'm not going to salute
you he feels like Jack Nicholson you
Salute Your superiors what Superior they
kicked you out
remember don't you sass me like your
mother this just got very real
yeah I own you and you will respect me
damn now you salute me
no you hit that boy again again I'mma do
more than salute you this is between me
and my son stepson whoever he is he's on
my time now that man
sweating hell yeah kick his ass pay yeah
please return to your vehicle Smart they
needed like a serious moment yeah an
hour and 10 minutes into the movie get
your one serious Mo now you understand
why he is the way that he is
major pain sir thank you I want to get
that trophy sir even better for me but
you won't steal it no sir you want to
win it I want to earn it
sir that's right rest of you men feel
the same
way yeah I guess so yeah suppos way I
guess that one kid not really but like
all right since everyone else said
it a this is a sweet
movie other than the whole future
domestic violent relationship that's
happen that's a later
problem eat eat like you've never eaten
before this going to be a fun game we're
ever going to
watch I think they should end on in like
an ambiguous way right before the game
starts just cut to Black
[Music]
oh I want to do some military training N
I know that sounds way too
tiring can barely get out of
bed oh oh
no oh oh what just happened
they got
twins oh no there's two of them okay oh
yeah the Death guy pass got it you look
so
racist jeez
Aaron godamn
it oh little
man
city just a little
bit damn Aaron you know we can't say
that in this video in major trouble
major be a pain for the ad suitability
[Laughter]
a he's willing to share his whistle blow
my whistle
baby oh what why is this becoming like a
real movie they didn't even hear the
dialogue that's crazy that's just visual
storytelling right
there I didn't sign up for real emotions
cute moment this just turned into like a
real fil moments like that why she
stays that's how you hook him just got
to apologize I've seen the Priscilla
Elvis
movie still a
sandwich you're just not a soggy
one that's means you got good feces
turds you've graduated strong stools to
maggots from turds to maggots let's win
them games these games better be awesome
there's been so much hype and buildup to
this you better not
lose we need you back but he can't go
back he loves these kids now America
needs you there's a situation in that
requires your special services no I
can't I love them now your unit will be
leaving out of Washington you will
arrive tomorrow at 1600 for briefing but
here are your T but the kids uh tomorrow
the military games and I was hoping
games I fought to get you reinstated you
want it in I got you in oh man
conflict the major will be there sir
good
man I'll see you in Washington all right
peace out kids I mean half of them have
daddy issues you might as well just
reaffirm he can be their daddy older
male mentors will abandon you they will
not stick around continue that cycle I
overheard that whole
conversation me leaving is training you
to be tougher where you going back to
killing you want to come oh damn what
happened to Unity and family and all
that other that you taught us I
never said family don't break up don't
you watch
Oprah you know when they're through with
you they're just going to cut you loose
again I asked to leave boys making me
soft them boys need you I need you look
woman T 11 separate engagements I didn't
do all that to come back and be
conquered by no woman and a bunch of
kids what you really think I was going
to do marry you ouch adopt tiger become
the loving male role model that's not me
it's not me
pain this is called is pain Dark Knight
of the Soul people screen writer ladies
and gentlemen every big movie Falls the
same structure pretty much it's why most
movies are predictable
[Laughter]
now all that growth what was it for
major pain what was it for major pen
just to regress I can't believe he
actually left Alex where are you going
he had to run from his feelings it
wasn't personal games you guys better
start getting ready we got to be there
in an hour we don't have to go to games
P's gone he's gone until he shows up at
the last minute to support you guys pain
or no pain I'm going to go out there and
win that stupid trophy pain or no pain
we got to gain the trophy I didn't go
through all that to come out
empty-handed AR you with
me I can't hit you yes sir he really
does have big ears you can't help it
Greg present arms stap present
Arington
present why someone like this some like
this what's up pick one Madison present
arms Cadet order
arms the Virginia
jroy got nothing to save you
bage come
on oh forgot about this game that's a
hard game it's all about the strats The
Leverage the grip damn poor
kid surprisingly good
transition that is not a white picket
fence it's really it's really messed up
fence
it's really ugly
Rock oh from Tiger my f get son I wish
tiger got the bullets out of that
closet there it is
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
boy it's
[Music]
laughing you know what you must do he be
honorably
[Music]
discharged damn kid get it kid come a
long
way oh I have never been good at rope
climbing he's over the wall go oh these
like buot cab drill stuff are was really
fun did tough mutter once that was
really
fun it going be really
fun CL thing I've done this is football
training my man get
it you going to trip him wow dude
cheer winner of the races when did he
switch sides I don't think he did fourth
[Applause]
place
you traitor oh dang I guess what the
hell you guys got to conduct yourselves
in a professional
[Music]
manner damn he's great I demand that the
entire medicine Squad be disqualified
from the final competition I can only
disqualify the cadet who started the
disturbance these animals are so
pathetic their on Commander didn't
bother to show
[Music]
up ain't no need for name
colge
good man good man who whoa whoa whoa who
I suggest we get this party started that
okay with you Colonel I'm pleased to
announce the two top rated squads who
will compete for first and second place
in the parade drill competition o here
we go Wellington Academy and Madison
Academy I would have ended this on a
much darker note where he shows up right
when they lose so was all for nothing
you're
pathetic now to give them some nice
morale in their loss lick their wounds
for next year I weirdly have a lot of
thoughts about this movie that I want to
share when the reaction's done so why'd
you come back be soft be soft maybe I
didn't come back for you Why'd You Come
Back Then for my boy and my woman I told
myself that I want to see you win first
place and ain't going to leave till you
do it's all about the trophy maybe I
like you just like
maybe I like you a
lot
that's it don't push the
baby let's win this thing we have nobody
to lead the drill of course we do tiger
he's little that boy know the drill like
the knob on the back head I can't do it
I'm too little you got this little
little Bloom you were The Little Engine
That Could you're going to shoot up this
place real team leader private Kevin
DK I think it's like a real a good
comedy and I feel like it had the
potential to be like a great comedy if
they just tweaked a couple of
things adorable little
[Music]
guy
good job kids I want to look up the
trivia on this movie yeah I'm really
curious what happened to all these
actors come on come
on yeah he got you
tapping oh my goodness hey oh my
goodness oh my goodness this why he was
hired damn is this real that looks real
that's yeah he's doing it for real
that's awesome
damn that's
awesome yeah Pump
It show how it's
done get
it
yeah your daddy taught you that that was
so
funny never forget it the kid was so
committed Orlando Bloom kid from Fresh
prins So committ or from that so raven
or TMZ slash three months later oh yeah
this teacher what a the random teacher
with the bugs the dean there's a Korean
flag there there's a Mex California flag
Mexico flag I don't
know I figure what the flags look like
did they
win
yeah good job good job guys you're
better than your abusive
stepfather sir Squad is formed
sir my name is Major Benson Winford pain
Winford I'd like for you to think of me
not only as your commanding officer but
as your
friend
and what the hell is that he's mine
uhoh oh that's cool he's the next
potential leader of this squad or he
just an you know there ain't no
pets allowed on these head premises Mr
Ace ventur yeah well maybe that doesn't
apply to me he's my blind cing ey dog oh
he's blind well would anybody want with
a blind
dog I'm the one that's blind you
idiot see you and your friend gujo here
got a little attitudinal problem needs
some readjusting hey
corpit corpit go tell Mom bring my fi KN
mom what do you care you're
blun kind of a creep creepy ass way to
end the movie really I thought I thought
they going do the circle in like a
Looney Tune
thing okay that interesting it was
Orlando Brown I called it he is problems
all right reject Nation so today I want
to share something with you that has
been a wonderful addition to my health
and fitness journey that I discovered
during the holidays and that is liquid
IV's hydration multiplier I'm down to my
very last packet and I'm freaking out
but it's okay I got more in the mail now
a lot of you have been so kind kind to
notice how I've been working on my
physical health thank you for all the
compliments and one thing I learned is
that proper hydration is absolutely
crucial especially post-workout and
pre-filming after post-workout and my
wife actually introduced me to this
product which is perfect because we not
only care about quality but a good taste
and quality product whether it's after a
sweaty workout or just after you know a
good night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolites is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm
always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero
sugar added because that's one of my
main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products
that fit that description that also
taste good too so yes thank you so much
so liquid IV's hydration multiplier is
in summary is they are a non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers
hydration into your blood stream faster
and more efficient than water alone cuz
sometimes drinking a whole gallon is not
always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water I'm also
big on efficiency plus it's packed with
love essential vitamins and we know
vitamins are good for the body it's
vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy
free you can customize the water amount
to your taste again perfect for post
night recovery traveling or just having
a big night out you know what I mean no
so if you want to booster support for
the channel and booster hydration game
go to liquid i.com and use promo code
reject at checkout that's liquid iv.com
promo code Rejects and remember liquid
IV it's not a real IV sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
all righty guys a classic one jeez Aaron
I'm trying to say the thing say the
thing if you're listening this on Apple
or Spotify I'm paying Aaron for 2 hours
and we got 21 minutes I'm going to get
every minute out of you Aaron I don't
care what we filled this
with we just watched major pain
today and Aon what was your expectations
before going into this this comedy uh my
expectations were a zil a zero um uh and
you know what they exceeded them they
exceeded they they met they became an
expect they met them and uh they did so
adequately uh I liked it I thought it
was fun I I definitely see why people
like this movie uh it had heart you know
even though that major pain was
definitely on the outside this character
of this tough and Military guy there was
heart there there was like a layer of
real character there underneath all of
the
uh the not satire but this like SNL
esque exaggerated character and seeing
him play against these kids who also had
their own individual things going on but
primarily Stone and tiger um yeah it was
it was a nice fun movie I like the music
I think that is there two no there's not
up
random uh yeah Damon Waynes really made
this movie he was hilarious from start
to finish you would think that the stick
that he was doing would get old but it
strangely didn't I laughed through from
start to finish and for a movie to be
almost 20 almost 30 Jesus almost 30
years old it came out in 1995 the year I
was born uh it yeah for it still to hold
up is just a testament to the quality of
the writing uh because you know we go
through movies that are of their time
you know each decade has their own genre
of humor uh that it kind of sticks with
and or plays with and some sometimes it
works in future sometimes it doesn't and
this for the most part worked uh yeah I
thought all the acting was really good I
really like the girl who played Hillary
I cannot remember her name U do you
remember that girl's name dude of course
I committed it to
memory the only remembered is Stone and
major pain and tiger and that's pretty
much it uh but yeah I was thoroughly
entertained I don't think it's like the
greatest comedy I've ever seen but it's
it's fun you know it's harmless it was
what what's her name Ken Parson Karen
Parsons she's still fine yeah she's
still hot damn I know getting off track
but damn Godot damn
woman uh yeah it had a lot more heart
than
expected I got a theory for you you have
a theory I was just having a random
guest when I was watching I was like
okay all the posters for major pain uh
he's turned profiled right looking over
at us that way yeah his reaction like
it's a very specific kind of poster and
then I started looking at all the other
posters I started looking on like okay
is this the original poster and it is
the original poster and my theory is
they had maybe some marketing thing
where they didn't really want the gold
tooth showing yeah because they were
like they might be unappealing for
audiences to look at and they might not
want to see it and get the wrong
impression might scare them might scare
them with a black man with a gold
tooth might offend uh military people
and I went a different direction you did
yeah I went with the black thing in the
military maybe both maybe it could be
both it could be both all right so here
before there's a okay IMDb has five
facts one of them is really long so I I
I want to get my thoughts first okay
then I want to go through these facts I
got you for 17 more minutes here and
Counting I've been going to go to the
bathroom the last 40 minutes oh really
but I'm hold it in oh God cuz every
minute with you counts for this two hour
are your
Bells okay uh yeah I'm with you I I I I
thought it would be a little bit more
like hideen spoof satire I mean there's
there's that uh spoof satire element
throughout obviously with like making
fun of uh drill sergeants and
specifically the kind of like drill
sergeants that you would see in uh
Cinema like I don't really know what a
real drill Sergeant's like I know
they're riing on real drill sergeant but
my only Association is with movies and
this this movie is like making fun of
like that type in a movie if you're like
what if you took this guy and you put
him in this scenario and I thought they
did a really fun job with that and to
liken it to like a a comedy today I
would kind of liken a little bit more to
like weirdly you don't have you seen you
Don't Mess with the Zohan Adam S no
actually never seen it well while it's
like a super silly film uh Adam Sandler
really did like Israeli military
training for it really bulked up for
this film about this lethal Israeli War
uh military man who comes to the States
to become a hair stylist but he but he
really got buff for it and he he did all
the actual training and everything like
they he really did all that and I got
the impression that they kind of did the
same thing here that while it is a
comedy they still had them go through
rigorous training I imagine even Damen
ways probably did like a decent amount
of actual research because one of my
favorite things about it was it did
start off where I had that same feeling
like okay this is funny now but is this
going to get annoying watching this one
note and then they managed to make major
pain become a real character through the
course of the film and they they never
had it go too far yeah which I really
liked where he gets like way too soft by
the end or some it was believable
yeah and then they had some surprising
heartfelt nuanced moments where there
could be a little bit of a serious scene
with major pain there and you could
believe the serious scene despite how
heightened this character is there's
some good visual gags throughout I mean
eron and I were joking about the this
kind of relationship is the thing
that's just not believable and get
ridiculed today for you know falling in
love with the man who would probably be
a real abusive kind of lover but it's
stupid silly comedy what do you what
does it matter I do think that yeah
overall the end goal of the movie is to
make you laugh and I I laughed quite a
bit it wasn't like I was laughing a
little bit and then suddenly I stopped
like this was a movie that one of my I
think my biggest laugh actually came
from the the Orlando Bloom Miss tiger at
the end when he was doing the Michael
Jackson dad like that was cracking
me up that's like towards the very end
of the film so yeah I thought it was a
really fun movie and I could see how
this is one that could probably feed
into a lot of people's Nostalgia who
grew up on it but this is us discovering
it and normally I I kind of separate
myself going yeah there's like a
Nostalgia film and then there's this
this is today as a new viewers like
whatever uh I I thought it would be more
annoying for some reason I've seen this
poster for so much of my life never seen
a clip or a trailer and I I always
thought it might be a bit of an annoying
film even though I've liked the weins
family and in like almost everything I
see them in so I don't know why I I I
like watch My Wife and Kids and uh I
watched um uh Wayne's Brothers as well
uh both those shows and then while they
while the movies and I've seen some of
their sketches from In Living Color and
I've seen a good amount of their movies
as well and Damon way is one who like
went off into being a director he like
direct Scary Movie one and two I did not
know that oh wow yeah yeah he's mainly
he's directed A lot of them of the the
ones that SAR Marlin and Shawn wayes
he's directed a good amount of them huh
yeah so he's he's kept him there kep in
the family right right let me before I'm
before I'm really wrong I think I'm just
going off memory here I I could be wrong
because so many there's so many weighin
brothers that I probably I'm wondering
if I'm wrong about that four of them and
then the a big Wayne's Brothers family
no no I'm wrong who's the keen and ivory
Waynes is the one I'm thinking of keen
and ivory way my bad yeah no Keen IV way
is the one who went off and directed my
bad okay glad I clear once I started
saying I was like no wait a minute I
think I'm off about that se The Last Boy
Scout um but yeah I've seen the sketch
Living Color I forgot that he's not the
one I want off to what did Keenan I
wayin do he we got I think he was In
Living Color we got 13 minutes Aon I'm
going to look up what Keenan I Wayne's
did
he he's done a lot of stuff I know he
used to do more stuff in the 90s being
on camera but not as much yes he's the
one who's like directs white chicks and
that's right my bad I got it confus w
okay the last yeah okay glad we are here
to where where is it the director
director little man white chick Scary
Movie Scary Movie 2 oh they brought back
In Living Color that's right I forgot
about that they did yeah look 2012
forgot they did that actually I didn't
forget clearly didn't last long I did
not know that um but yeah
uh I think D way and Damon way has a kid
who's also called Damon wayes right yeah
Damon way Jr yes she new girl yes yes
yes yes okay there's a lot of Wayne's
Brothers there's a lot of it's a big
Wayne's family wayman's of them and
there's the next generation of Wayne
there just the ones you know about
that's true all right Aaron we got 11
and a half minutes left I'm going to
look up how many
wein what is the size of the wein family
that's not the way to ask the question
but let's see if this Google knows what
I'm talking about come on Google come on
AI I should have said how many members
are in the we's family be a lot 10
siblings damn see five brothers and Five
Sisters that's a shitload of kids look
at that look at that poor mother Keenan
Ivory sha Marlon Damon and Dwayne Wayne
who the hell is Dwayne he's like I want
no part of this family
business who is Dwayne
wein oh he's a real human being
it's been a long time since I've seen
White Chicks but did that movie have
heart do you remember kind of because
what what makes me think of that is you
know this movie had that balance of him
being a caricature and and over the
course of the movie developing heart and
being like a a real guy
to some extent but I'm like watching it
and he has the these his scenes where he
does his like his bits you know like the
The Little Engine That Could and like
the whole dancing aspect of things or
the that one scene but you know it
doesn't feel like how they would try to
do comedy in the 2000s it still felt of
the 90s but it wasn't overbearing no
still in that that realm of like okay
this is still entertaining this is still
funny rather than trying too hard to be
like ha you get it we're doing a bit
well here's what I think would have
helped elevate this movie from being a
like a good comedy to a masterpiece of a
film I'm here to tell you how this could
have been maybe the greatest movie ever
made
ER I I don't I don't mean to oversell
but I think I can deliver the goods what
they could have done is a I think we
they could have had a little more of
those Nuance serious doesn't have to be
serious but not go for like go for the
laughs uh when you're just cutting to
the kids when they're by themselves that
way we can really get to know the
children so you have a contrast when you
cut to major pain where you're kind of
in a different type of like Wacky World
and then you're in a world with the kids
where you get a little bit more of
getting to know their personality is
where they come from why they're here
why they are the way they are like that
the whole thing with the kid and his
stepfather comes in like pretty late
into the movie and kind of getting an
inkling of that for the character Arc
probably would have helped serve the
narrative a little bit better you know
and I feel like that one ingredient
would have helped flush all this out
because this whole thing about the games
I'm like I don't really know what what
the I know the game's it's more than
just like a trophy there's there's got
to be a deeper meaning to it than that
you know but why and I think if if they
had and I thought this movie at times
was a little bit at odds of wanting to
just be that wacky comedy because
there's three screenwriters here so I
thought at times it was that odds would
wanting to be the wacky comedy that as
advertised and then oh but you know we
really do want a little more Harden to
be kind of like Kindergarten Cop or
something I don't know one one of those
movies where you get more Nuance to to
so you're more connected to the kids
yeah and and I think that was the
missing ingredient because I'm like I
don't really know who the the kids
personalities is that well other than
you only know like three of them you
know tiger the guy the one who's the
douche who leaves them and then the main
guy right and but everyone else even has
like a camaraderie and stuff like I
think there were felt like there was
like missing scenes or stuff that they
just rewrote or cut out where if we got
more of I guess what I'm talking about
is like whenever you're cutting with
them that's where you really get a start
growing the heart for it so you care
more about major pain connecting with
them you know and then I think they
could have perhaps dialed back a tiny
tiny bit towards the end like just get a
inkling more of who major pain is not a
lot I'm not saying a lot
but when they have these opportunities
when he's bonding with Hillary whatever
her name is he's bonding with with the
girl from
freshz uh if you got a tiny bit more of
like beyond the military yeah and
something from his childhood yeah I'm
not saying you have to go like deep
psychoanalysis or some but the the
movie was obviously wanting to to go in
that terrain I think the movie wanted to
like that's why they have the book about
emotional nurturing being an adult male
role model reading a psychology book
they have like these when he first
argues with Hillary when they first have
a blowout just dropping like these
adjectives of like real psychoanalysis
term you know so I think the movie
actually wanted to sort of explore that
and they were kind of I don't know it's
the 90s I don't know how worked
back then so maybe they were told to
like you know temper it hold it back be
more fun you know I I I have no idea uh
but I do think more of the the heart
wanted to be there kind of threw out and
they were kind of told not to or they
were told to edit it out because
especially with like Damon Wayne's being
a co-writer and and like the main thing
I love from him all most people love
like In Living Color or the other things
he's done um some people even liked him
in the Lethal Weapon show the the I I
know him for My Wife and Kids mainly
like specifically this Wayne's brother I
know him for my wife and kids which is a
very heartfelt show about family and it
was really funny and I really liked it
and I I think that this movie is
actually Shining a lot when they are
doing more of the the stuff with Hillary
so bad forget your name wrong stuff with
her I think that's when they were
definitely um showing a little they're
not like a husband and wife but that's
when you start seeing the the
relationship side of it and then with
tiger the father side the stuff that
really shines in my wife and kids and
this is on My Wife and Kids production
so clearly this is this is a that is a
theme in a topic when it comes to
narrative storytelling that Damon ways
himself is very much drawn to so maybe
there was a specific script and Dam ways
came in and said we should Implement
some of this or maybe there was an
inverse I don't know either way I think
if they had more of that it would have
helped make the wackier stuff even
funnier yeah you know and they would
have had some actual stakes and
investment in the game because even the
movie when they're done with the game
they just dissolve too and they you
don't get a wrap up on on our kids no
when I'm like oh that's kind of a bummer
to me you know or or even with Hillary
God damn it yeah they kind of they kind
they did kind of treat them as a bit of
an afterthought yeah cuz we they start
to do that in the beginning like okay
these are these kids different
personalities as he's like giving them
their their uh their punishment for
their acting out or whatever and yeah we
start to see some of that like the like
the thick kid who was eating the the
cookies and stuff I would have liked to
see more of him and like the the kid who
had the his head shaved who had the big
ears and like yeah I agree that
camaraderie would have made things a
little bit stronger and I I would have
liked to know more about Hillary too or
whatever the hell her name is um and you
know maybe her relationship with with
tiger you know and then that adds and
plays into their perspective of the the
whole family thing because the way that
it ended where major pain leaves it just
treated them as the focus for that one
scene or that one segment of the movie
and then ending it Without Really seeing
where they go cuz there some of them are
still in the line like uh at the end of
the movie and just ending it on major
pain not really showing the followup of
what happens with him and Hillary what
happens with him and Tiger's
relationship what happens to the team as
a whole I would have liked to seen all
of that and yeah that's it's unfortunate
but may hey maybe left on The Cutting
Room floor maybe they're like all right
this is a 90s movie we got to wrap it up
yeah you got time for none of that uh
let's see here okay I'm going to look at
re I'm speed reading some quick facts
here all right to research his character
Damon Wayne's endured several weeks of
di qualification training learning the
requirements to Marine Corps drill
instructor as well as other aspects of
Marine Corps training viewers can see
several small things he does like the
Cadence of his walk see this is the
thing I'm talking about where I'm like I
felt like he actually prepared for the
role and that's what I mean like you
wouldn't just do that for just a wacky
comedy I think there was more care in
there that they wanted to implement
along with the wackiness you know almost
unconsciously correcting his cover after
berading and getting in the face of each
Cadet and the list goes on and the b
list basically just goes on the stage is
how much more he uh he stayed in there
and even improvising he was a lot of it
was embodying the character all right
okay there's actual accuracy to the
uniform he's wearing one of the kids is
the one he says um he says I'm not your
brother that is actually deak Williams
that is Damen Wayne's nephew oh cool
usually put their kids in there it's
cheap cheapap cheap cheap let's see
here uh Dam Wayne's character was
dancing to Pop That Coochie by two two
Live Crew in the nightclub scene uh
interestingly enough Waynes was having a
real life Feud with two life crew at the
time due to a joke he told about the
group during his comedy special
oh way to rub it in their face I liked
hearing you readed Pop That Coochie that
was funny um yeah hey Aaron we got two
minutes
left uh Martin Lawrence was offered the
role of major pain but turned it down
cuz he was making bad boys with slap
artist Will Smith I could have totally
seen him as major pain too he would have
been great
uhuh let me just go
no was this one a minute and a half
left okay pH I like the score too I
thought the score was was
fitting oh check this out in interview
with is true it's good a good point on
the on the score here um in an interview
Damon Wayne said that at the beginning
of filming he was advised by technical
adviser Dale D to meth act and dist
himself from the kids in the R Group
when the camera wasn't rolling similar
to what Lou go Jr had done and An
Officer and a Gentleman see I think they
wanted to make a real movie right you
don't make those choices for that kind
of that kind of preparation for a
pure comedy no I got those inklings of
like the filmmaker or the writing that
probably had Studio notes to I don't
know just keep it keep it simple or
something keep it light uh but no yeah
cuz that they get heavy with the steps
dad coming in slapping the kid around
like this is rather Ser this like
serious this is dramatic scene that was
the most serious thing that happened in
the movie it was like a little jarring
for to go like that real and then go
back to to the tone we were expecting we
were used to but uh overall with what we
got the product ultimately delivered was
a funny film and I'm glad we saw it and
we got to experience the Nostalgia a lot
of people get a experience we got 40
seconds left here um this video itself
will not be two hours but the recording
is two hours got to get that who's your
favorite weigh
in Marlin wow done the most well just by
quantity not by quality of an artist
he's done the
most he's bidden more things he's my
favorite by that measure I'd be like
Nicholas Cage is my between Marlin and
him because I grew up on him and uh all
my wife and
kids he's he's a classic I miss him I
wish he'd come back Damon we miss you
still does stuff when was the last time
you saw him in something oh two hours up
all right thank you guys so much for
being here uh leave a like And subscribe
and we'll catch youall soon I gotta get
him out of here before he charges me
more you
know M Lyon hey M M M it's a new year in
Sweden or Switzerland I don't know it's
been a couple years I always forget
which one they sound the same to me I
don't know what they look like I don't
know what what you sound like I don't I
don't know the difference what is he
Sweden I think he is
Swedish wait did you forget I you
remember it was like you said both names
so many times he was like doing the
shell game I was like where is the Pete
uh yes he's he's in Sweden I I yeah my
mind leans towards Sweden every time but
I constantly question it because I'm
like I don't know what Switzerland or
Sweden looks like and I don't know what
what the difference is because I don't
know what any I don't know anything
about you guys sure and you've educated
us before but it's all left my dumb
American brain once a year you should
come back here and educate us on your
culture anyway look you got to have a
New Year's resolution regardless right
you you swits must do that you must have
don't celebrate the new year or sweet
yeah you you must have a you must have a
New Year's plans so here's your New
Year's resolution I'm going to give it
to you because I know you probably
haven't thought of it cuz you guys down
and uh uh Estonia never think about it
right you Romanians man oh so what your
shout out is your your New Year's
resolution um oh I knew exactly what was
going to be all right um You are going
to buy many mirrors you're going to set
up many mirrors that way when someone
breaks into your home to try to shoot
you you can do the taunting monologue
game oh yeah and you can like flip
around and be like where am I now and
then there'll be surrounded by mirrors
and then they shoot at you and but it
cracks with you don't Flinch they sh
that wasn't you they shot they shot the
mirror not you and you give a laugh and
you step out of frame and leave them to
languish hit them over the oh yeah that
no no no in confusion before you hit
them over the head hit them over the
head yeah you sneak up on them that's
when you get the drop but you see the
thing is like you know the problem is in
these like spy and action movies that
you're obsessed with uh male is like
they don't prepare for a scenario when
do they ever take the time for a
training session to learn how why is it
always they know how to manipulate the
mirror situation but the bad guys don't
know how to manipulate the mirror
situation so you got to train you really
got to train to figure out how the
mirrors bounce off each other to be able
to properly manipulate and trick the the
bad guy when they break into your home
of how to you
know scare them yeah you need to learn
the layout of the you need to spend a
month living in complete dark so you
know the lay out just instinctually and
then you need to do a lot of different
studies on yeah what angles are the best
what looks the most cinematic because
the thing is if you're going to mess
with you know like a a a burglar coming
in you can't just do it in a normal
efficient way you have to taunt them and
make it clear that you're the boss and
they messed up by coming into your
domain and please do not for the love of
God please do
not attack until they say where are you
yeah it's very that's the most important
part
facts this sh yeah dude there you go man
Mel seriously all right you're the best
Norwegian we know best Norwegian all
right you take care of your Viking
sisters and brothers out there and you
let us know how everything is going and
uh Happy New Year te you buddy
[Music]
yeah